game number four of this four game
series and josh james getting the start
and taking his spot in the rotation 27
year old from hollywood florida looking
to shed long junior
just like that
a four pitch strikeout is
josh james wasted no time going to work
on shed long here's the rookie evan
white who made his major league debut on
friday night this will be his 23rd pitch
of the first inning
and a swing and a miss and he gets his
man couple of strikeouts for josh james
and a couple of men left for the
mariners welcome back kendall graveman
and it's nice to hold george springer in
check they've done a heck of a job
that's a big strikeout to get things
going south to bay
look at his face did you see him look at
his face he came out griffin like what
was that there's alex bregman the pitch
and it's strike three called on the
outside corner bregman is caught looking
kendall draven in the comeback holy
smokes strikeout to side here in the
bottom of the first inning what a return
for kendall braven bases loaded nobody
out top of the third swinging a ground
ball up the middle right to correa the
shortstop shaded he steps on second
throws onto first base in time for the
double play
shed long junior scores from third
there are two outs but the mariners jump
on the board first it's one to nothing
here's evan white first standing rbi
yesterday came with two outs
oh boy he got that one look at this home
run up in white is first in the major
leagues
turn that baby around and the mariners
the three-nothing lead boy that was
great congratulations evan white evan
white off to a hot start
what a beginning to his career
three-nothing mariners we saw that power
evan white going deep against josh james
here in the top of the third for his
first major league home run here's
altuve he struck out look at his last
time up
trying to break through here against
kendall graveman
that one ripped down the line it's a
fair ball that'll get into the corner
kyle tucker rounds third dustin garneau
headed for third base he'll be held
there as jose altuve
with an rbi double and the astros are on
the board it's three to one there you go
altuve with a big swing to break the
seal there's bregman
watch that one
it is
gone career home run number 100 for alex
bregman got one to hit and he did not
miss it bregman stepping up in a big way
made the adjustment got a fastball
mistake up out over the plate stands up
on it and is in the sentry club alex
bregman's 100th home run
puts the astros up 4-3
cardo walked and scored on alex
bregman's 100th career home run here's
the one-two
that ball's poked left field going back
on it d gordon he's on the warning track
still going back still going back and
it's off his glove and off the wall it's
a base hit tucker around third he'll
score garneau skips into third base
and he's got himself a triple and an rbi
is 5-3 astros with a 5-3 lead over the
mariners as jose altuve the batter
altuve to left field d gordon will turn
around and watch this one head to the
crawford boxes
take out a couple of cutouts on the way
altuve's first homer and the astros lead
continues to grow this guy's amazing we
talked about how quickly he could get
warm and get going i think turning on
that fastball the previous av helped him
how about and he knew he wasn't gonna
get called out on this one like he did
his first at bat recognized the high
fastball got the barrel out in front and
just enough to get that into the first
couple of rows of the crawford boxes six
to three astros bregman at first nobody
out the batter michael brantley
michael brantley that went down into the
corner as he turns on it
extra bases for brantley
bregman around third he'll be wave throw
to the plate and he'll score
astros on top seven to three michael
brantley an rbi double so runners at the
corners with one
out reddick into right field and the
astros now take an 8-3 lead correa goes
into third base and another rbi double
second one of the inning josh reddick
drives home another run got a little bit
quick but off the end of the bat ends up
being a double down the right field line
because he was running right in the face
of tim lopes these guys been running
around making them look good
here's seeger
[Music]
it's a fair ball
gorielle takes care of the out crawford
scores 8-4
houston league evan white earlier today
connected on his first career big league
home run that's with one out and one on
the payoff pitch
swinging it sliced into right field for
a base hit it's booted by redick in
right field that's enough of a window to
open up for kyle lewis to steam around
third base and score standing
evan white drives in his third run of
the day the mariners inch closer it's
8-5 astro
roberto sooner to the mound so jose
marmaleos
bats with two outs in the ninth inning
seeger goes ground ball eule's there and
the astros take three out of four
from the seattle mariners to start the
2020 season the astros win it by a score
of eight to five the astros get it done
tonight